CONFERENCE IN DALLAS TONIGHT.
IT COMES AS THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE RAMPS UP ITS
INVESTIGATION OF JANUARY 6th AND
THE INSURRECTION FALLOUT IS
FRONT AND CENTER AT CPAC.
THE MOST BUZZED ABOUT BOOTH IS
THIS.
A FAKE JAIL CELL.
WHAT YOU'RE WATCHING ACTUALLY
HAPPENED AT CPAC.
IT FEATURES A CONVICTED JANUARY
6th RIOTER DOING PERFORMANCE
ART, IF YOU WANT TO CALL IT
THAT, IN A CAGE WEARING AN
ORANGE JUMP SUIT.
ALSO ON DISPLAY, CULTURAL WARS
AND ELECTION DENIALISM.
>> WE'RE AT WAR.
THINK ABOUT AFTER HIGH NOON ON
THE 20th OF JANUARY OF 2021.
WHEN AN ILLEGITIMATE IMPOSTOR
TOOK OVER 1600 PENNSYLVANIA
AVENUE AND TOOK OVER THE
ADMINISTRATION.
>> MY JOB, IT'S LIKE THE OLD
COLISEUM WHERE YOU SLAM ON A
BREAST PLATE AND GO FIGHT THE
BARBARIANS.
>> WE'RE GOING TO SECURE A
BOARDER, BUILD A DAMN WALL, THEN
WHEN WE FINISH IT, NAME IT AFTER
PRESIDENT DONALD J. TRUMP.
>> A LOT OF THIS SOUNDS
FAMILIAR, BUT THE HITS, I GUESS
THEY KEEP THE FOLKS COMING IN.
WHAT ARE YOU HEARING FROM THE
ATTENDEES THERE?
>> WELL, JIM, IN JUST A FEW
HOURS, AS YOU SAID, DONALD TRUMP
WILL TAKE THE STAGE.
THE FINAL SPEECH HERE AT THIS
THREE-DAY EVENT.
HE'LL BE PROCEEDED BY TWO
REPUBLICAN CANDIDATES.
MICHIGAN AND ARIZONA, BUT TRUMP
IS THE BIG STAR HERE.
HE IS ENDING THINGS IN A COUPLE
OF HOURS IN THE BALLROOM.
A FEW ATTENDEES ABOUT WHAT THEY
WERE EXPECTING FROM DONALD TRUMP
TONIGHT AND WHETHER THEY WANT TO
SUPPORT HIM IN 2024 IF HE
DECIDES TO RUN FOR PRESIDENT.
>> DONALD TRUMP REALLY STANDS
FOR KIND OF THAT HE'S AGAINST
THE ESTABLISHMENT, RIGHT, BUT
THESE DAYS EVER SINCE 2016, LOT
MORE PEOPLE ARE
ANTI-ESTABLISHMENT.
DeSANTIS, ESPECIALLY, BUT THE
REASON WHY I ALWAYS GO FOR TRUMP
IS BECAUSE TRUMP REALLY HAS THE
ABRASIVENESS.
>> I LOOK FORWARD TO JUST ABOUT
EVERYTHING HE SAYS.
WHETHER IT BE TALKING ABOUT
SECURING OUR BORDERS OR TALKING
ABOUT REFUNDING THE POLICE AND
SUPPORTING THEM.
I'M VERY PASSIONATE ABOUT THAT
AS WELL AND GOING AGAINST
SENATORSHIP.
THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS ABOUT
OUR FREEDOMS THAT ARE BEING
ENFRINGED UPON.
>> I'M MORE IN FAVOR OF RON
DeSANTIS.
I THINK RON DeSANTIS IS LIKE A
NEW IDEAS AND HE'S YOU KNOW,
YOUNGER.
>> YEAH, DEFINITELY MORE IN
TOUCH WITH THE PEOPLE THAN
DONALD TRUMP IS.
>> AND THAT LAST GENTLEMAN WAS
REALLY AN OUTLIER HERE, JIM, AT
CPAC.
YOU SEE A LOT OF TRUMP 2024
STICKERS.
T-SHIRTS SAYING THINGS THAT THE
2020 ELECTION WAS STOLEN.
IT REALLY IS A COMMON THEME HERE
AT THIS CPAC.
SORT OF TRUMPIFIED CPAC.
YOU MENTIONED THE JAIL CELL
FEATURING SOMEONE WHO WAS
ARRESTED FOR THEIR INVOLVEMENT
IN THE RIOT AT THE CAPITOL DOING
THAT PERFORMANCE ART THERE.
YOU COVERED ENOUGH OF THESE.
THERE'S ALWAYS A DASH OF
SPECTACLE.
WE'LL BE SEEING PROBABLY MORE OF
THAT TONIGHT FROM DONALD TRUMP
IN JUST A COUPLE OF HOURS.
JIM?
>> APPARENTLY, MARJORIE TAYLOR
GREENE PAID A VISIT TO THAT JAIL
CELL.
QUITE SOMETHING.
MICHAEL WARREN, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
LET'S DISCUSS THIS WITH A PAIR
OF FORMER REPUBLICAN
CONGRESSMEN.
PODCAST HOST, JOE WALSH IS WITH
ME, AND CHARLIE DENT IS WITH US
AS WELL.
JOE, I HAVE TO TAKE YOU BACK TO
THAT BIZARRE PIECE OF VIDEO FROM
A FEW MOMENTS AGO.
SOME KIND OF SYMBOLIC JANUARY
6th RIDER IN A JAIL CELL DOING
FAKE SNOW FLAKE TEARS.
I DON'T KNOW IF IT'S CPAC OR
SUMMER SHAKESPEARE.
>> JIM, I ALWAYS LOVE BEING ON
WITH YOU BECAUSE WE'RE ALWAYS
TALKING ABOUT MY FORMER
POLITICAL PARTY AND I THINK
WE'RE ALL JUST HAVING A HARD
TIME WRAPPING OUR ARMS AROUND
THE FACT THAT THIS IS WHO THIS
PARTY IS.
I MEAN, THAT WAS A CRAZY THING,
RIGHT?
JANUARY 6th DEFENDANT IN A MOCK
JAIL CELL, BUT WHAT DOES THAT
MEAN?
IT MEANS EVERYBODY AT CPAC, THEY
DON'T BELIEVE JANUARY 6th WAS A
BIG DEAL OR BAD THING.
THAT'S WHERE THE BASE IS.
AND AGAIN, WE GO THROUGH THIS
EXERCISE EVERY WEEK OR TWO.
THE COUNTRY NEEDS TO UNDERSTAND
MY FORMER POLITICAL PARTY IS
FULLY ANTI-DEMOCRACY.
IT IS A FASCIST POLITICAL PARTY.
IT IS A POLITICAL PARTY THAT
EMBRACES AUTHORITARIANISM.
>> MOVING ON IS THE TRICK HERE.
THE PARTY DOESN'T SEEM TO BE
DOING THAT AT THIS POINT.
AS WE WERE HEARING FROM MICHAEL
WARREN A FEW MOMENTS AGO, THIS
IS A TRUMP CPAC AS IF YOU KNOW,
WE WERE LOOKING AT THE YEAR 2020
OR 2019, AS IF JANUARY 6th AND
THE INSURRECTION HADN'T REALLY
HAPPENED.
DOESN'T THIS SPEAK IN PART TO
KIND OF THE VICTIM COMPLEX AT
THE HEART OF THE TRUMP MOVEMENT?
>> NO QUESTION ABOUT THAT.
TRUMP IS THE ULTIMATE VICTIM IF
YOU JUST ASK HIM, BUT I THINK WE
SHOULD TRY TO SEPARATE WHAT GOES
ON AT CPAC, WHICH HAS FRANKLY
BECOME A FREAK SHOW OVER THE
YEARS.
IT'S REALLY NOT REPRESENTATIVE
OF THE COUNTRY AND NOT OF THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY, EVEN TODAY.
I THINK MANY REPUBLICANS AND
MANY AMERICANS DO SEE THAT
DONALD TRUMP IS A DIMINISHING,
YET STILL A DANGEROUS FIGURE.
LOOK WHAT JUST HAPPENED IN THE
KANSAS REFERENDUM VOTE ON
TUESDAY.
CLEARLY A LOT OF REPUBLICANS ARE
UNCOMFORTABLE WITH WHERE THE
PARTY'S GOING.
REPUBLICANS VOTED AGAINST THE
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT ON
ABORTION.
I THINK THERE ARE A LOT OF
REPUBLICANS OUT THERE, I'M
GUESSING AT LEAST 30%, WHO ARE
NOT COMFORTABLE WITH WHERE THIS
PARTY IS AND WANT SOMETHING
BETTER.
LOOK WHERE CPAC IS.
THEY'VE GOT THESE NATIVISTS,
STEVE BANNON, ORBAN, AND MIKE
LINDELL.
WHAT IS HE THERE FOR?
BANNON HAD JUST BEEN CONVICTED
FOR DEFYING A CONGRESSIONAL
SUBPOENA.
THEY SHOULD CHANGE THEIR NAME
FROM CPAC TO ILL PACK.
THIS IS SICK WHAT THEY'RE DOING.
YOU ALWAYS HAVE THESE OVER THE
YEARS WHERE THE POLLS ARE ALWAYS
WIN AND THEY WERE GOING TO WIN
PRIMARIES BUT THAT'S WHERE CPAC
IS THESE DAYS.
>> JOE, YOU WANT TO RESPOND?
>> JIM, I LOVE AND RESPECT MY
FORMER COLLEAGUE.
NO, THIS IS WHERE THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY IS.
LOOK WHO'S WINNING REPUBLICAN
PRIMARIES.
ELECTION DENIERS LEFT AND RIGHT.
ALL YOU'VE GOT TO DO IS TUNE IN
TO TUCKER CARLSON EVERY SINGLE
NIGHT YOU WANT TO KNOW WHERE THE
TYPICAL REPUBLICAN VOTER IS.
HATEFUL, BIGOTED, AUTHORITARIAN
NATIONALISM.
THIS ISN'T JUST CPAC.
THIS IS THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
BASE NOW.
>> CHARLIE, YOU MENTIONED VIKTOR
ORBAN, THE AUTOCRAT WANT TO BE
LEADER IN HUNGARY.
EVERY YEAR, CPAC SEEMS TO BE
MORE AND MORE ABOUT POLITICAL
THEATRE, BUT WE SAW ORBAN AS
THIS CONFERENCE.
HE OPENED IT UP.
IT'S OPENING IT UP WITH A
DICTATOR WANT TO BE AND CLOSING
IT WITH A WANT TO BE IN TRUMP.
LET'S LISTEN.
>> THEY'RE OBLIGED TO PROTECT
THE CHRISTIAN CULTURE OF
HUNGARY.
SHOULD PROTECT THE CONSTITUTION
OF MARRIAGE AS THE UNION OF ONE
MAN AND ONE WOMAN.
FAMILY TIES, FAMILY TIES SHALL
BE BASED ON MARRIAGE OR THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN PARENT AND
CHILDREN.
TO SUM UP, THE MOTHER IS A
WOMAN.
THE FATHER IS A MAN.
AND LEAVE OUR KIDS ALONE.
END OF DISCUSSION.
>> CHARLIE, WE JUST HEARD YOU A
FEW MOMENTS AGO SAY THIS IS NOT
WHAT THE REPUBLICAN PARTY IS ALL
ABOUT.
BUT HERE YOU HAVE AMERICAN
CONSERVATIVES CHEERING A
PRO PUTIN DEMOCRACY, SPOUTING
NATIONALIST RHETORIC, ANTI-GAY
BIGOTRY.
IT IS A DOMINANT FORCE IN THE
PARTY THOUGH.
IS IT NOT?
>> WELL, LOOK.
THERE ISN'T A LIBERAL POP LIST
NATIVE MOVEMENT.
VIKTOR ORBAN, THE LA PEN
MOVEMENT IN FRANCE.
ITALY, GERMANY, BREXIT.
AND OF COURSE TRUMPISM IN THE
U.S.
THIS IS A DANGEROUS TREND.
THIS IS A LIBERAL AND I WOULD
AGREE THESE PEOPLE HAVE
AUTHORITARIAN LEADINGS AND
ADMIRE AUTOCRATS.
THIS IS A MAJOR PROBLEM FOR THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
NOT TRYING TO DIMINISH THAT.
WHAT I'M SUGGESTING IS THAT NOT
ALL REPUBLICANS AGREE WITH THIS.
ARE THERE NOT REPUBLICANS TO
STOP THIS MOVEMENT INSIDE THE
GOP?
IT LOOKS AS THOUGH TRUMP IS
WAITING IN THE WINGS AND PERHAPS
TRUMP LIGHT IS RIGHT BEHIND HIM.
>> NOT YET.
DO I THINK TRUMP IS DOMINANT IN
THE PARTY AT THE MOMENT?
YES, I DO.
AND THAT'S, THAT'S DEEPLY
REGRETTABLE AND I THINK
SHAMEFUL.
WITH THAT SAID, WE NEED TO
EMPOWER THOSE, LIZ CHENEY'S,
PETER MYERS, AND THERE ARE OTHER
REPUBLICANS WHO DON'T LIKE WHERE
THIS PARTY IS GOING.
YES, THEY ARE THE MINORITY, BUT
THE PARTY ESTABLISHMENT, THE
PARTY LEADERSHIP AS IT IS NOW,
THE TRUMP WING, THEY WANT TO
CONTINUE TO LOSE ELECTIONS, THEY
SHOULD CONTINUE DOWN THE PATH
THEY'RE ON BECAUSE TRUMP HAS
BROUGHT NOTHING BUT DEFEAT TO
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY.
IN REC